[Applauso]
attorno alla prima metà del secolo
scorso Qualcuno
ha detto che è necessario un nuovo modo
di pensare perché l'umanità possa
continuare a vivere Scusate il tedesco
la lingua originale della citazione
perché se andate a googlare la citazione
in italiano la frase non è corretta
parlano di sopravvivere vaital significa
continuare a vivere noi vogliamo
continuare a vivere non sopravvivere per
cui bene questo qualcuno non era un
qualcuno ma era un fisico teorico forse
il più grande di tutti i tempi che
sicuramente non faceva rifaceva
riferimento problemi ma sicuramente non
problemi come quelli ambientali che
abbiamo oggigiorno connessi a si parla
sempre di cambiamenti climatici di crisi
idrica Infatti dei cambiamenti climatici
frequenza sempre maggiore diventi
estremi e il sesto e idrogeologico come
potete vedere dalle immagini
inquinamento atmosferico Beh
L'inquinamento è una la coscienza
ambientale sull'inquinamento è venuta
fuori negli Stati Uniti intorno agli
anni 70 Pensate un po' e altra Piccola
parentesi è un po' immagino un po'
triste e la Pianura Padana se qualcuno
non lo sa è considerata la maglia nera
del pianeta Per quanto riguarda
l'inquinamento atmosferico
però c'è anche del positivo
progetto che sto curando che adesso in
conclusione con
come unico responsabile dell'università
di Ferrara il Comune di Ferrara e tanti
altri bravissimi partners che è una coda
europea che ha portato alla città di
Ferrara a 5 milioni di euro per
migliorare la qualità dell'aria Adesso a
ottobre dal 5 al 7 c'è la festa
dell'aria che è uno degli eventi
conclusivi della progetto e sono tutti
invitati a partecipare ci sono un sacco
di belle iniziative chiudiamo la
parentesi e mi faccio sempre
accompagnare da all'inizio di questo di
questo mio Talk da Einstein perché per
per Einstein la crisi non era negativa
perché la crisi inizia significa un
punto di partenza per nuove strategie
per nuovo modo di pensare per impostare
nuove nuove sfide
posto che cambiamo il percorso che ci ha
portato alla crisi perché non possiamo
pretendere che le cose cambino se
continuiamo a fare quello che facciamo
quindi dobbiamo reimpostare il tutto
quindi perché utopia perché non
lazionalità logica perché sempre
Einstein diceva che il vero segno
dell'intelligenza non è la conoscenza ma
l'immaginazione la logica la razionalità
sono ingegnere ci porta da AB Ok ma
l'immaginazione il sogno ci può portare
dovunque anche a fare quello che non
penso che la logica dice no non si può E
in tutto questo cito anche Steve Jobs
che nel discorso prima della sua morte
all'università dei suoi studenti
dell'università di Stanford diceva Stay
on Grey state siate affamati siate folli
e Beh anche Roberto Benigni che io stimo
tantissimo a Sanremo ha detto chi sogna
arriva prima di chi pensa non so se
qualcuno si ricorda Google bene allora
pensiamo troviamo tutti a essere un po'
visionari di questo mio discorso che sto
iniziando e a pensare a non
necessariamente cose complicate Anzi ha
un modello di sostenibilità che sia più
in equilibrio con la natura Perché
diciamo che l'uomo qualche danno un po'
l'ha creato Parliamo di una risorsa la
risorsa più importante per l'uomo per
l'ambiente Senza la quale nessuno può
vivere Ecco non possiamo pensare
di continuare con il vecchio modello con
il classico modello di gestione della
risorsa idrica secondo il quale c'è
l'accumulo e la ricarica nel periodo in
cui c'è l'acqua per poi utilizzare
l'acqua quando non c'è perché questo
modello sta dimostrando ha dimostrato
continua a dimostrarci di fallire Beh
quando facciamo il semplice esempio
della Primavera inverno primavera estate
dell'anno scorso l'acqua non è arrivata
abbiamo avuto i fiumi
i corpi idrici superficiali quindi le
falde ai livelli minimi storici Ma è
vero anche il contrario Purtroppo quando
di acqua ne arriva ne arriva troppa e
crea disastri anche a lungo termine
quindi
disastri con anche perdite di vite umane
quindi non va più bene cosa fare
pensiamo a un altro problema l'Italia è
tutta costa abbiamo
l'enea sono modelli previsionali stima
per la fine di questo secolo un
innalzamento del livello mare tutti ne
parliamo A livello mondiale pensiamo
all'Italia Enea tra i 095 e 1,45 metri
secondo gli scenari si fanno siamo noi
facciamo scenari modelli al computer
facciamo lo scenario più cautelativo
quello meno cautelativo perché sempre
bene fare essere considerati entrambi i
casi quindi siamo nell'ordine di
grandezza di un metro o anche un metro e
mezzo Beh pensiamo a dei territori
caratterizzati con questo scenario
caratterizzati anche da un territorio
che è subsidente
ce li abbiamo qui e pensiamo anche la
presenza di un corpo idrico superficiale
che sfocia a mare ce l'abbiamo qui e
pensiamo a una situazione estrema che si
può verificare in cui abbiamo Alta marea
mare in tempesta fiume in piena può
succedere che il mare non consenta al
fiume di sversare le sue acque per cui
le acque del fiume in piena si riversano
penso all'entroterra bene senza far
riferimento a qualcosa di recente
pensiamo per esempio al 2005 uragano
Katrina
l'80% di New Orleans Lusiana unire
States
hanno provveduto con le dighe foranee Ok
ma pensiamo data la frequenza sempre più
estrema sempre più sempre nella maggior
frequenza di eventi estremi dobbiamo
continuare a ragionare in maniera
emergenziale o è bene iniziare a pensare
in termini previsionali a volte Beh ero
piccolina i miei genitori Purtroppo
anche loro entrambi ingegneri mi hanno
portato in Olanda vedere le dighe quindi
è da un po' che gli olandesi hanno vinto
la loro battaglia contro il mare con
Lady che foranee Beh anche il Mose
progettato costruito nel 2003 in
funzione dal 2020 C'è voluto un po' però
funziona quindi si può l'utopia può
essere realtà Beh anche un'altra quando
ero studiavo sono laureata ormai sono
passati vent'anni e sistemi di accumulo
erano le dighe sono le dighe
caratteristiche delle dighe Qual è
l'impermeabilizzazione deve essere
impermeabile non deve perdere acqua beh
adesso inizia a parlare lo vedremo anche
di sistemi di accumulo sotterranei Beh
sistema di accumulo sotterraneo anche
che consentono infiltrazione fa da cosa
che prima non era possibile bene
ragioniamo Cosa cambia tra accumulo in
superficie e accumulo in profondità
lasciamo stare l'infiltrazione in falda
se io accumulo immaginate Quanta acqua
Io posso perdere si accumula in
superficie per evaporazione e quanta
acqua non perde invece risparmio si
accumula in profondità
beh Ora pensiamo alle nostre città una
decina di anni fa i nostri amici cinesi
amici o ci collaboro Insomma sono
bravissimi però hanno combinato anche
loro Un po' di anoniquinato hanno
costruito che realizzato super metropoli
Però anche loro si sono resi conto di
aver esagerato e che dovevano cercare di
reimpostare il pensiero di rimpostare le
città in che senso
rendere tornare a prima cercare di
replicare il naturale drenaggio del
terreno che esisteva prima
dell'edificazione quindi come
realizzando delle Nature base Solutions
soluzioni naturali Quindi niente di
strano che rendevano le città assorbenti
quindi città spugna Sponge City quindi è
nata il concetto di Sponge City per
realizzarlo ho fatto uno schemino mio
mentale bisogna ragionare però a tutte
le scale già la scala di edificio poi
eventualmente Sicuramente Sicuramente a
Scala Maggiore quindi a scala di
quartiere poi a scala di città e poi per
chiudere il bilancio dato che purtroppo
essendo un ingegnere si chiude il
bilancio nel dominio di studio e quindi
si ragiona a scala del dominio entro il
quale si chiude il bilancio idrico che è
il bacino idrografico e quindi a scala
territoriale scala Maggiore cerchiamo di
ragionare un po' a scala di edificio che
cosa si può fare a scala di edificio Beh
si può fare si possono realizzare degli
invasi di detenzione quindi raccogliere
accumulare l'acqua scala di edificio
accumulo l'acqua che posso utilizzare
per lavare le auto per lavare le scale
per irrigare
posso realizzare tutte le forme di verde
orizzontale verde verticale che sono i
tetti Verdi i giardini pensili le
facciate Verdi Living Wars che
sottraggono dell'acqua ogni volta a
seguito di ogni evento meteorico che poi
restituiscono Naturalmente per
evapotraspirazione in atmosfera si può
fare già qualcosa ma aumentiamo la scala
andiamo una scala Maggiore pensiamo a
quartiere so se qualcuno ha mai sentito
parlare di Rain Gardens giardini della
pioggia e sono del dei pezzi di verde
dei tratti di giardino di avvallamenti a
bordo strada realizzati artificialmente
o naturalmente che consentono
l'infiltrazione in fase Quindi anche
grazie al potere autodepurante del
terreno la filtrazione e la depurazione
dell'acqua se poi ci inserisco anche
specie antismog possono anche Depurare
l'aria l'Australia che è la mia second
HM e piena di Rain Gardens ma anche
Stati Uniti e possiamo realizzare dei
sistemi di accumulo sotterranei ci sono
anche sistemi che si sentono poi
all'acqua di infiltrarsi in falda e di
andare a ricaricare le nostre care falde
acquifere a me carissime e possiamo
realizzare invasi di detenzione a Scala
locale che sono anche qui dei piccoli
avvallamenti che si possono allagare a
seguito di alcuni eventi o invasi di
ritenzione che sono già piccoli stagni
che possono essere allagati
ulteriormente un'altra Non so se
qualcuno ha mai visto in Olanda l'Olanda
né piena infatti sono stati loro ad
inventare le piazze d'acqua a livello
Urbano Le Piazze d'acqua sono
semplicemente delle piazze progettate
per
assorbire filtrare l'acqua a seguito di
eventi medi meteorici e poi essere
completamente allagate a seguito di
eventi intensi e Beh mi è venuto mi è
venuta questa da aggiungere questa
immagine non è una piazza d'acqua ma
potrebbe esserlo si allaga questi ma non
ero non ero a Ferrara quel giorno ma ho
visto le immagini dei surfisti e
quindi andiamo a Scala ancora Maggiore
andiamo a nel macro sistema ossia scala
urbana cosa Possiamo aggiungere beh le
Metropoli ormai Londra hanno gli Urban
Wilson parks Quindi questi grandi parchi
urbani l'abbiamo anche in Cina la
costruiti tanti il sabato 16 Park nato
dalla riabilitazione di un ex parcheggio
di autobus e poi ci sono anche varie
altre forme di verde come corridoi Verdi
come diretrici Verdi lineari che corrono
parallelamente ai corpi idrici
superficiali come per esempio
Auckland che le infrastrutture Verdi
hanno unito una serie di parchi una rete
di parchi E pensate che una classifica
che ha preso Campione 30 Metropoli
mondiali ha fatto una classifica per
potere assorbente quindi potere
assorbente delle città
e ha classificato o clan dal terzo posto
Auckland se qualcuno è la città più
grande del della Nuova Zelanda non
essendo la capitale e bene altro esempio
di corridoio verde Urbano è nato in Cina
per la seguito della riabilitazione di
un sito post di un sito un braum sito
industriale degradato mi viene più
facile certe parole in inglese e a scala
più grande abbiamo quindi a scala di
bacino tutti voi o tutti quasi tutti
Insomma abbiamo
declassicare di laminazione che è già un
approccio consolidato Ma c'è qualcosa di
più che non è stato tanto implementato
un'altra utopia realizzare delle aree di
lagunaggio in corrispondenza della Costa
Cioè vado a realizzare dei bacini di
stoccaggio dell'acqua in corrispondenza
della Costa Questo è un esempio è stato
difficile trovarne e cosa Vado a
risolvere oltre quello quando noi
sappiamo il territorio costieri vivono
in equilibrio tra Terra e Mare Noi siamo
in Italia viviamo in costante equilibrio
terra mare bene se non piove le falde
vanno giù
il mare abbiamo visto Sta salendo Beh il
mare avanza ogni estate si parla di
Cuneo che avanza Cuneo che avanza bene
se io vado a evitare che tutta
quest'acqua vada il ranoffin in
ruscelamento al mare vado a rimpinguare
le nostre falde acquifere contrasto
l'avanzamento del mare quello che noi
gergo nel termine tecnico chiamiamo
intrusione Salina e quindi è un ottimo
un ottimo un ottima tecnica da
realizzare nelle zone costiere e poi
abbiamo anche quello che fanno nelle
grosse Metropoli le cinture Verdi
intorno alle città anche quelle a non
poter assorbente o nelle Metropoli
mondiali quelle scandinave volevo dire
che hanno i fiordi i classici cunei
verdi o Fingers dita Verdi secondo il
modello Stellare di città
Ma quindi Dov'è In tutto questo l'utopia
l'utopia è proprio nel tornare indietro
e nel ricostruire Considerando la natura
in equilibrio con essa
aggiungo qualcos'altro Il World water
Development report degli United Nations
le nazioni unite Nel 2020 ha scritto
lo dico in inglese poi lo traduco anche
unventional Times Call francavention
water resources cioè il tempo non
convenzionale Richiede l'utilizzo di
risorse idriche non convenzionate per
esempio se io vado a prendere dell'acqua
dall'umidità dell'aria o se vado a
utilizzare la reflui per produrre
elettricità Queste sono delle risorse
non convenzionali ma non è tanto nuova
come cosa se pensiamo che i nostri
archeologi hanno trovato nelle zone
desertiche deserto di Atacama quindi
l'India in India Scusate il link in
Egitto in Israele territorio
caratterizzato da sempre fanno la lotta
per avere l'acqua Sono bravissimi di
israeliani come gestione dell'acqua bene
e hanno trovato questi sistemi
secondo i quali tramite quali loro
prendevano acqua dall'umidità dell'aria
bene un esempio di un brevetto
israeliano che stiamo applicando per il
progetto europeo è un vassoio
semplicissimo Cioè non le cose più
semplici sono quelle più più più in
equilibrio con la natura un vassoio in
polipropilene che consente insieme
inserito sulla base della pianta di
catturare convogliare verso la pianta
tutta l'acqua di condensa di rugiada
l'umidità dell'aria e quindi consente un
risparmio in termini di irrigazione
questo per chi parteciperà alla ci sarà
una passeggiata si vedranno tutti questi
vassoi E tutto questo ci sono Quindi
questi sistemi si chiamano atmosferico
vuoto generators c'è un altro brevetto
che è un idrogel che consente di
ricavare sempre acqua dal umidità
dell'aria utilizzato nelle Urban Farming
l'agricoltura è un settore super
idroesigente Beh se riusciamo a
ottimizzare anche l'acqua
nell'agricoltura abbiamo fatto bingo
in tutto questo un altro esempio di
economia circolare di ottimizzazione di
Risparmio idrico è la serra idroponica
in cui io
coltivo la pianta in acqua con soluzione
ammendanti nutrienti
il non plus ultra l'economia circolare
al 100% risparmio idrico fino al 95%
dato dall'abbinamento della della
idroponica con L'allevamento di pesci
quindi si chiama acquaponica e consente
cosa i rifiuti le acque organiche dei
pesci vengono depurate dalla dalle
piante che li utilizzano come sostanze
in materia nutritiva che poi depurano
l'acqua rientra in circolo c'è un
circolo perfetto quindi e quindi un
risparmio fino al 95%,
l'ultimo esempio di utopia che vi voglio
raccontare e quindici anni fa torna
quindici anni fa ho lavorato con i miei
colleghi del Politecnico di Bari dove mi
sono laureata e ha un'utopia ha un
qualcosa che è stato considerato da
tutti
irrealizzabile No non si può non va non
funziona Beh questa idea che vi dirò tra
brevissimo è stata brevettata ha avuto
brevetto Patience International italiano
e internazionale ed è stato poi
industrializzato Quindi anche qui
richiamo il mio amico che dice che tutti
sanno che qualunque cosa impossibile da
realizzare finché arriva uno che non ci
pensa è la realizza
cosa consiste
immaginate cioè consiste nella
produzione di energia a livello anche
condominiale perché lavora a temperatura
corporea senza nessun tipo di emissioni
CO2 emissioni né cattivi odori acqua
quindi l'utilizzo della materia organica
più le acque reflue più eventualmente
gli sfalci del giardino per produrre
metano acqua e terreno agricolo in soli
due giorni rispetto ai classici sistemi
che ne impiegano 30-40 tutto questo che
significa significa appunto che riesco a
utilizzare quello che è il rifiuto per
produrre energia in due giorni senza
emissioni senza cattivi odori e quindi
questo significherebbe che se ogni
impianto condominiale ogni condominio
avesse questo sistema potrei non aver
bisogno di una serie di cose tipo
raccolta dell'organico reti per il gas
potrei avere delle produzioni ogni
edificio indipendente questo è un'utopia
per il momento il brevetto non lo è
perché è stato industrializzato ma
questo è quello che potrebbe essere il
nostro futuro per cui poi vado a
considerare le nostre città come un
insieme di positive manager
positiva se io ci aggiungo anche la
produzione di energia rinnovabile con
tutte le forme dell'energia rinnovabile
mini turbine eoliche con minimo impatto
acustico o fotovoltaico eccetera
eccetera Beh questo è un'utopia è un
sogno
però gli manca qualcosa Ora penso che
magari qualcuno ha già l'idea è per non
perdere troppo tempo vado velocemente
anzi vi racconto una delle ultime cose
che ho fatto su cui sto lavorando
l'energia rinnovabile discontinua Oggi
ne ho tanto caldo tutto il caldo che ha
fatto quest'estate tutto il caldo
energia tutta persa beh
E se tutto questa energia noi l'avessimo
potuta
conservare accumulare per poi
utilizzarla quando arriva dicembre
gennaio in quelle dose giornate di
dicembre gennaio febbraio Perché No beh
questo è possibile
si può stoccare l'energia ma non
necessariamente mille metri di
profondità anche a pochi metri di
profondità e adesso ci sto lavorando a
livello modellistico ma anche sto
impostando dei modelli di laboratorio
nella scala di laboratorio per poi
andare anche a scala di campo per poter
accumulare stoccare l'energia solare
termica nel sottosuolo e poi
riutilizzarla qui ho fatto una
simulazione per un centro sportivo ma in
teoria si potrebbe fare anche a
ognuna ogni piccola scala Questo è
un'utopia adesso oggi che ve lo racconto
Ma io spero che questa speculazione
questa insieme di idee di sogni di
visioni possano essere una base concreta
per ragionare per pensare per poter
reimpostare meglio le nostre città
[Applauso]